so you you've taught a bit of high
school is that correct i didn't know
that so yeah uh for five years after i
got my doctorate um before i was made a
regular on the big bang theory about
your doctorate who are you i i'm just
like
jesus franco but for five years you're
so impressive i know you've come here
like so many times and every time i just
i just want to be you every time you're
here i'm like you're so impressive just
a lot of layers to this onion i know
it's such a freaking awesome onion but i
did i taught for five years i designed a
neuroscience curriculum for junior high
and high school homeschoolers i taught
in the la homeschooling community wow um
i also taught high school biology which
is exactly what it sounds like i taught
sex ed to a group of teenagers yeah
somebody's gotta teach them someone has
to teach them amy fowler from the big
bang series
i learned on a school bus so i think the
way you did was probably better i
learned when i taught them you know it
was like just a short number of years
like we're all learning together i have
two kids i don't know how it happened
wading through the trauma together
[Music]